one man's story of redemption finding
inspiration in the world all around us
rodney stotz is his name he used to be a
drug dealer think about this for a
second he turned his life around by
forming a very powerful bond with birds
and nature
he's sharing his experience the new book
bird brother a falconer's journey and
the healing power of wildlife so he
talked to ben tracy who also met some of
stott's fine feathered friends
good boy
it's been more than 20 years since this
eurasian eagle owl
named mr hoots first perched on rodney
stotz's arm this is my son here but he
remembers it like it was yesterday the
first time that bird is on your hand and
you're looking in that bird's eyes and
you get lost
you're gone you're lost
if something happened with that bird
believe me i'd be in a straight jacket
locked up somewhere i'd really lose it
come on that connection is what began
stotz's journey to become one of the few
black master falconers in the country i
think when most people hear falconry
they think of somebody who likes birds
what exactly is it
falconry is actually the oldest
landsport it's the actual sport of
hunting birds of prey so you would go
out you'll catch a wild bird hawk falcon
and you would actually use that bird to
get dinner for you guys that night good
boy working with these magnificent
creatures didn't just become the focus
of rodney stotz's life
it's also what changed it in some way
you feel like this
saved you oh definitely
you think about where you would have
been not could have been where you would
have been either jail or death
in the 1990s stats was living in one of
the most dangerous neighborhoods in
washington dc
at the height of the crack epidemic
he wanted to be a lawyer but realized
there was an easier way to make money
drugs that's the quickest way you're
going to make money how much money did
you make selling drugs at an average
week maybe around fifteen thousand
dollars fifteen thousand a week
in a 2005 story about people turning
their lives around through environmental
work a then 34 year old stats told 60
minutes at bradley about his time as a
drug dealer and why he finally stopped
you can't enjoy life you can't feel
proud about anything that you have
because it was ill-gotten gains stotz
spent time in prison but began to clean
up his life by cleaning up dc's polluted
anacostia river with the earth
conservation corps he also helped to
reintroduce the american bald eagle to
the nation's capital he found his new
passion and a new look on his mother's
face seeing my mother eyes light up when
i come in the house and i had a bird or
something as opposed to a gun
when she heard the am lambs coming and
she know it wasn't about her son anymore
you know to start seeing those things
that's what falconry started doing for
me when i tell people that it's
different for me
than it is for the average falconer left
hand now anyone willing to extend a hand
can share his experience hi
i think you just winked at me mr hoots
those eyes are amazing
stats says he prefers animals to people
but he does make a few exceptions don't
underestimate your accomplishments he
tells his story to at-risk teens from
dc's capital guardian youth challenge
academy
who helped him build a new aviary for
bald eagles on this land in maryland to
see it up and see y'all doing it man
that's a beautiful thing he's a good
teacher it was cool to see
another person that's my color do such
amazing things in the community what is
it that you're hoping they learn from
you from your story just never give up
you're not the mistake that you make
unless you continue to do it i tell them
the same thing i tell my kids
allow yourself to be wrong
admit
when you look in that mirror if you say
i gave it all i have and i'm proud of me
i'm proud of you your title's not wrong
you're going to lose your bird and
rodney stotz is now living a life that
also makes him proud of himself for cbs
mornings i'm ben tracy in laurel
maryland
so you know rodney's right life is long
it's got a lot of twists and turns right
and what you do in your worst chapter is
not who you are right don't let it
define you yeah go wrong that breath in
your body you have an ability to
redefine yourself on a yearly basis
daily basis no i love what he just said
you're not the mistake that you make you
know what else i love the owl's eyes
yeah those are captivating to me and the
way rodney so tenderly kisses them too i
like that the owl was named mr hoots
mister
i like that oh rodney styles yeah